hi everyone it's me again
what a surprise um okay
so um today
i had an endgame from
uh a game between magnus
and karwana i think you guys can read it
in the title right
so um wait actually let me
let me make this a tiny bit smaller
so you don't see the settings underneath
um yeah so
i think this is good
staunty i feel like every time i want to
change the p set it's it's a
it's a mistake so
i don't know but today uh i had planned
to talk
about a very nice end game between
carlson
and corona um both
extremely powerful extremely extremely
talented players they're
both playing in the uh why can't say or
that's still happening right now i think
you guys
most likely have seen the event um
so definitely check it out i remember
that the
carlson ferruccia game from around one
was very very nice
um actually as i was saying like a
moment ago in the other
in the other lecture um i was playing a
tournament in the charlotte chess center
and oftentimes like before our rounds uh
there was like the live coverage
um of the titans still on the on the tv
and we would all just kind of gather up
and watch it up until it was time to
play
so we did uh kind of watch that
tournament
um as it was happening and i would
recommend you guys to
to watch it if you're not watching it
already but this is this game is not
from that tournament this is from
2012 and i guess the first thing i can
ask you guys
is what do you think of the position
usually there are
a few different things that you guys
need to consider you need to consider
of course first thing is a material uh
the placement of the pieces how are the
kings doing
and the pawn structures so
um so first thing i should ask you guys
is what do you think about this thing
game is it just a plain draw so should
they just like
agree to a draw you know right now is
there a chance to win for
for either side what do you guys believe
seeing this position
would you play on if you were if if if
you were playing a caesar color
what do you think is the king
weak or active in the end game i don't
know do you think it can get checkmated
on f3
um white has a good king draw
okay material is equal black should have
a slightly better pawn structure
but what has a better king um
do you actually think that
black has a better pawn structure
because i i guess i understand you in
the sense that
white has more pawn islands
but at the same time which pawn do you
think is naturally weaker in this
position this one or this one
because i would say the b7 pawn is also
a backward spawn
so
what do you guys think
black has a past pawn um i wouldn't
really consider
the b7 pawn about the pass pawn because
it's fixed
by the opponent on a4 so it's never
going to be able to
to actually get all the way to where he
wants because the pawn on a4 is just
simply stopping it so
all right so if you had to play for
either side
what do you guys think
like if you had to play either side if
you were looking at this position it's
like okay
pick a side what do you guys think
you would play white okay any other
thoughts white white
essentially this is uh most likely
close to equal end game
but if there is one side that has
chances
to win is white so this end game is not
straight up winning for white
and it's also definitely not a
not a technical force to win of course
it's more practical than that um
but there are very small factors that
kind of help with this
with this narrative so the first one is
the king of f3
it is so much better than the king of g8
no it is not a weak king
because we are in the end game and not
only that the king
can only be weak if it goes towards the
center if it can get checkmated and in
this position it doesn't feel like
black has enough pieces to to get a
check made it
and i say this a lot on my streams a
weakness
is not a weakness unless you can attack
it and right now you can't really
go after the king on f3 so
it just happens to have several tempos
um
over the the black king on g8
so um that's one thing
also probably the most arguable thing is
that you guys were mentioning white has
three pawn islands
meanwhile black has two and usually you
want to have as less point at
phone islands as possible but right now
the opponent's c3 is better protected
than the pawn on b7 the pawn on b7 is a
backwards spawn and it's never really
going to be able to cooperate with the
pawn on a5
because it's backwards so um it's it's
always gotta be defended by
actual pieces no pawns so and the bishop
on d4 has some solid control of this
the bishop on c7 has less mobility than
this bishop so
they're all very very small factors but
they compile up if
if black doesn't play this right
so i want to ask you guys let me flip
the board real quick
if you guys wear black pieces in this
position which is actually black to move
what's your first instinct like what do
you do
also remember in end games of bishops
with the same color
you want to put your pawns the opposite
color of the bishops
so that they cannot get attacked by any
means
you usually want to put the pawns on the
opposite color
i mean now there are rooks so it's maybe
a little bit more flexible that rule
but essentially
that's one of the things you have to
keep in mind
king of fate you want to trade rules uh
rook sorry but
um but after king of faith there's
bishop c5 yo how to
uh watch out for that um
f5 holding back the black the white king
um i guess that could be a possibility
i'm kind of worried that the phone gets
weak somehow
but i don't see a way where that can
happen right away
maybe something actually maybe something
like f5
and then rook takes takes
and rook b1 with the idea of getting
into b5
maybe that's a thing actually
maybe that's the thing
um yeah
a better move would have been
um a better move would have been h5
and the idea of this is that you're
going to do
with this move you're kind of preventing
g4
and you're kind of stopping white from
getting all of the
the control or the space that they want
um
so with h5 you know if they want to play
g4 you can trade and that's fine
um and you're kind of uh
restricting white a little bit so
h5 is kind of the most natural move here
is it the only move not really
but it's kind of just the most natural
move in this position because you're
restricting white from playing g4
and g4 is a move that they do want
because they put the pawn on a light
square but at the same time
it controls space on the king side so
um yeah
so h5 is the move that black would have
liked to play
however they ended up playing b6
so um
they ended up playing b6 oh
uh how can they get the king out then
you can play like f6 king of seven
but um but
h5 is kind of you know a move that you
should have thought about earlier
yeah sorry h5 carpool just sat up from
his bed
um i mean
yeah b6 is not really a pretty move
right like the other bishop on c7 is
kind of stuck
having to defend upon right that's not
what they would want to do
um rookie three and rookie one we're
gonna see that idea
soon we're gonna see that idea soon
so after b6 rook b1 was played putting
pressure on the pawn
rook ac8 it's kind of indirectly
um defending the pawn because
for example um
let's say if
let's say if rook takes
takes takes there's gonna be rook b8
now do you guys think that this is still
okay and you can play something like
bishop takes rook takes and bishop takes
c7
or do you think that this line is not
good not
good to give up the the um exchange
to get the two pawns
like would you actually consider getting
the bishop and the two phones for the
rook
or do you think that it's not enough
no sure since the promotion squares
aren't dark
not good okay so you guys seem to not
like it
from what i can see right now
not good if you're not a gm yeah the
issues of the pawns are falling later
so i'm glad you guys noticed that so for
example after takes
takes bishop takes there's going to be
rook to c1 and when the bishop comes to
e5 to defend even to a5
it's the same story rook a1 and the
spawn on a4
is falling so essentially
you're just going to have the spawn and
that's not enough to win
and you may even have to be careful and
fight for a drone so
yeah so this line wouldn't have been
good
but in this position
why this about to take the the next step
on
you know improving their position and
trying to get more dominant and inside
the black territory
what are we doing we're looking at this
practical ending
between carlson and corona
it's two rooks and bishop bishops of the
same color that's very important
and it's how white slowly built up an
advantage
and created a win out of it
so g4 that's one idea they just made
like a more
active move um like a more controlling
move
now
yeah rookie four is very nice yeah
uh you can trade a pair of rooks and
play rook b5 but that may be too many
trades
like after takes takes rook b5 the rukan
comes to e6 and it protects the pawn and
it cuts the king
so the rook is very nice on e6 you don't
really want to give your opponent a
chance to
to have active defenders or active
pieces
um but rogue e4 is a very nice move
because you know if takes
takes now the king is closer and he can
get in
and that's definitely not what black
wants and also all of the white pawns
are protected
so it's not like you know after
something like this here
there you can get in and suddenly all
the pawns get traded off and it's a draw
it's not really the case there's just
like king c6
and their position is super good for
white um
so they do not want to trade rooks they
do not want to trade rooks on e4 because
the king can just get in um
therefore at this point they're just
kind of
hoping to to double up the rooks and get
control of the file right if they want
to
or they can start bringing the keys and
the king over to the other side
but the rug on e4 is a very nice move
um what about rookie 4
f5 okay
rookie 4 f5
now it feels like something that was
mentioned earlier can be done now
which is take 600 b5 now
they don't have time to play rook to e6
as i mentioned because the
f5 pawn is hanging and not only is the
f5 pawn hanging but when you play the
rook to b5
the rook is now protected by this phone
so you can take here
oops sorry you can take here without
worrying about this pin
that we have before remember that the
rook was on b1 and it wasn't really
protected by anything
now it's protected by the pawn a4 so
we're threading it upon on b6 end up on
f5
and there's no way they can defend both
of them at the same time
so yeah
i mean usually in this end games you may
not think about it but
there are very subtle tactics oftentimes
and that's why they're so difficult to
play
because if you miss one small tactic
then you're kind of busted
so uh usually in endgames
you kind of need to yeah play
kind of play more freely more
practically more
according to principle then in middle
game
because in middle game you have more
pieces you need to calculate more make
sure that there are no tactics
but um yeah in england you also need to
keep your eyes open you can't just
blindly um play
solidly you know without thinking
because you may miss a tactic and if you
do
it's probably a lot harder to recover so
just saying and i know it's difficult
because it's the last stage of the game
so you're probably tired from the
from the whole game that you have been
playing so far but
it's really important to to stay awake
in endgames too so yeah
and i would really recommend you guys
reading books about in games like the
wrestling game manual
the cell man book 100 games you should
know
uh practical in games all of those so
i mean not all of those you can read i
mean you can read all of those if you
want to but it's a lot of content
i would just recommend you to check them
out i know chessables has some
some courses and some of those i think
chess ball has a course on 100 games you
should know so
if it's easier for you to do it that way
too but yeah and games are important
because you don't want to play a pretty
awesome game
and then screw it up in the end game
because you didn't do the right
technique
so yeah
but okay so after rookie 4
g6 was played now what do you guys think
of g6 here
like is it really meaningful or do you
think well it's a move
decent okay
a bit weakening that is true
f6 is better um h5 actually would have
been a lot better
yeah it's difficult to get out with the
black king
yeah so g6 according to
uh the commentators of of this game
uh g6 is kind of like the losing move
um maybe it's not like straight up
losing but it makes a position like so
tough to defend
that it's like almost losing and the
reason why
is because well it doesn't really
achieve anything it weakens the diagonal
it also weakens upon an h6 and now after
uh the move g4 which is very very strong
the pawn on h6 is going to be kind of
fixed there
uh on the same color of the bishop so
just we can
we can just go and attack it and if you
ever play h5 you know the the
pawn structure is about to mess up so
uh it's not like you can play this move
and
um essentially the opponent h6 is just
gonna be fixed white has control with g4
and the position becomes a lot more
pleasant the king can't really do
anything
it's just not really a move that you
needed to make
so g4 is very strong because it
restricts
the pawns from black and at the same
time
again space on the on the king side
so essentially what you want to do is to
try and fix your opponent's pawns on the
same color of the bishop
and that's what they did to the h6 pawn
right now and you see that the h6 pawn
it may be like
well how are you going to attack it but
eventually you're going to see how it
was done
and little by little the more that
white controls more space in the
position
the more difficult it's going to be for
for black later on because
um
i don't know it's just they won't really
have
great moves so
essentially you're kind of restricting
black more and more and more
as the game progresses and it becomes
more and more difficult for them to make
moves
which prompts them to making like a
radical move
that ends up being a really big weakness
so yeah
all right so g4 was played as i was
mentioning
um h5 would have been a little bit
better
in this position uh so that if they play
you know g4 at least there's going to be
some traits
and then maybe you can play like f6
bring the king to f7
uh but g6 is an inaccuracy
g4 extremely strong move and now
uh king f8 was played
now do you guys think f5 is a
possibility
there is like a tactical reason why it
isn't
what do you guys think
and this is why it's important to
do tactics or no tactics even in the
ending
just to make sure that your lines work
out
rookie three now you guys have something
more active
you guys have actually a way to win a
pawn
i'll give you that hint
oh you guys are seeing it kind of yeah
not rookie six because the rook can take
it so that's not
really great um
but let's see so after
takes takes root takes root takes
there's this really nice move from g1
using the fact that we have
kind of split up the pawns from
the the pawns from black and
after king f8 you don't want to play
king f7 because of rook g7
and you're going to go after this bishop
but after king 2
f8 there's this really nice move from g6
and you're attacking both and this rook
doesn't have an active
square where you can defend both of them
or anything
so yeah
um what do you guys think about this
line
it's very nice right because you know
you managed to infiltrate your rook and
once you take the pawn on h6 actually
like the opponent h
can move fast and
h8 is actually covered by the bishop so
if you manage to take the h61 it's
really nice
but yeah both pawns are falling and the
position is collapsing overall for
for black so yeah black is done kind of
kind of um
kind of so let's see
h4 sorry g4 king 2f8 was played
and now h4 what do you guys think is the
idea of this move
what do you guys think is the idea of
this move
remember what i was mentioning earlier
about opposite colored bishops
exactly so the idea is to play h5
the idea is to play h5 and fix this pawn
on h6
so that when we can afford to trade
pieces
and once we do that we can go after the
h6 spawn
take it and win the ending it's usually
very very nice
if you have end game with minor pieces
or just with some pieces
and your pawn structure is better so
that if you
trade some of the pieces you can win the
end game like that's that's
usually like a huge huge thing because
you can't afford to do trades so you can
kind of force your position to
to work out if that makes sense because
you know if you provoke trades you're
gonna be fine
so yeah h5 is the idea of fixing the
pawn on h6 and then in the future again
you can go after it and take it so so
yeah
um but yeah h4 is a very nice move
now rook takes e4 was played uh bishop
d8 could have been another move looking
after this
uh rook takes king takes doesn't really
achieve anything
the spring brings the king closer to the
center
but here you can play h5
and after take stakes upon a on h6 is
fixed
and
wait
is there bishop g7
oh did i miss that somehow
i think bishop g7 can take striptex
there's this maybe
yeah there is probably this and then the
bishop can take on each form
i think and that's the reason why you
wouldn't necessarily want to go for this
because let's say if king g2 for example
there may be bishop takes rook takes the
rook here
and now the end game is not super clear
um magnus great
contribution as a world champion is to
look at it
in game and 0.10.01 and then say winning
i mean it's only he who has that ability
most of the time
but yeah if rookie rookie three i think
uh
or did someone start rookie three now
essentially this is a threat
and this is a threat and this is also a
threat so it's not super clear
how to continue here as as as white
but yeah i'm guessing that's why bishop
g7 doesn't work
i kind of forgot that was a move
honestly but
i'm glad to see that unfortunately
you know doesn't work but after bishop
d8
um you can continue with h5 and after
takes takes
rook to e7 rook to g1
oops sorry rook to g1 with the idea of
bishop to g7
and taking on h6 later rook to c6
defending
rook eg4 rook to e6 and after a g8 king
up
rook h8 and now the other rook is going
to come in
and this is winning so this would have
been a
variation
this would have been a variation
um but they didn't play bishop d8 they
just played
rook takes e4 king takes e4
rook 8 and what would you guys have
played here actually
if your white pieces what would you do
came the 5 for king d3
king f3 i thought about that one
you wouldn't necessarily want to go back
to that side of the board you kind of
want to enter with your king through
through the kingside
okay so let's see hindi five is a very
active move
uh however i think uh maybe what carlson
didn't like was through e6
still the position is super good for
white he just decided to be a slightly
more cautious and he played king d3
um but i mean the the
the options both of them are good
hindi three e6 was played still
defending
bishop to e3 now attacking this pawn
king a7 rook b5
bishop to d8 h5
group d6 king c4 this is all looking
great so far
rook c6 king d5 of course this is not
possible why
why is that not possible
yeah bishop d4 bishop d4
and there's no no good follow-up for
black
so after king d5 carolina decided to go
back to
to e6 bishop d4 was played king 2f8
moving the king back bishop f6 would
have been another move
but this is not actually very great so
they could have played with takes
if bishop takes rook takes one takes
king takes e4 and white is winning
because they have a past one
so after bishop f6 group takes they had
to dig on b6
bishop takes takes keen c4
bishop one king b5
nc kf6 f3
g5 takes what do you guys think about
this singing
like i said just draw is it winning for
one side
draw winning for white
seems certainly winning for why don't
need to count for a sec though
yeah it's important to calculate the
same games you don't really want to get
into them
and then realize that you and your
opponent are promoting at the same time
when you had an objectively winning
position so
yeah it's really hard to cover it upon
exactly so for example here after bishop
dia18 takes
a5 bishop back a6
bishop a7 and now bishop b6
king bishop to b8 and
king to c6 and the king is going to get
into b7
and there's no way to stop this um
and i'll give you guys a hint that
usually the bishop wants
two long diagonals to prevent the pawn
from promoting
and of course here they only have sorry
here they only have one diagonal they
don't really have another one you can't
really consider this
diagonal so this end game is a loss
so yeah
um how about immediately bishop b6
uh like here we should be six i guess
that's also an option
and then you go around with your king
and then play this
but yeah so bishop f6 also takes b6
unfortunately and the bishop end game is
not
as equal as it may look at first so
after bishop d4 king 2 f8 was played
now what is the next step of the plan to
keep gaining space
to keep controlling
controlling and pushing black backwards
because you know the king is already
good the the rooks are already the
rook is already good the bishop on d4 is
very good
uh what is the next step
f4 but what is the idea
yeah exactly the king is safe f4 is
actually very nice
and the idea is that you're later
going to play with f5 right so
f4 bishop to c7 was played and now f5
and you see how you're keeping your
pawns uh how white is keeping their
pawns on the opposite color as the
bishops
and never ever ever are the pawns going
to be attacked this way
because the bishop can't really get to
them you know and the rook alone is not
going to go after the pawns and take
them
so the pawns are getting fixed on the on
the right square on the right color
rook d6 was played king to e4
rook to c6
and now a very nice idea was played
and yeah exactly h1 is weak is there a
way you guys can make use of the fact
that the h1 is weak and
can you guys do kind of like a um
second weakness type of attack like the
main weakness is
b6 now you go towards the second
weakness
put pressure on it until black's
positions collapses so
um there's a way you can regroup your
pieces right now
to go after the pawn on h6
and i mean pieces not just like be three
or something
like you know all of the pieces
it's more of a plan than just one move
screw this we went before this um
hopefully that would be very nice if you
can
a change on u6 and then what
what happens after that
any ideas
rook b3 you can move the rook to a
better square than b3
the bishop can stay on d4 for now
you don't really need to get it to e3
right now
rook d4 i don't think that's possible
though
root d5 um that could
maybe be a move uh rook d5
maybe king e7
[Music]
i mean it does look fine but why did
like a stronger plan
how do you go after the pawn on h2 with
your on h6 sorry
with your rook is there a way you can go
after it with the rook
what do you guys think
takes on g6 to open up the file um
they made a move before it but yeah it
could be an option
we can play actually uh this move
group h1 and it's a very nice idea
because you're bringing the rook all the
way over to h1
see so you're going to bring the rook
all the way over
and it's going to put pressure on h6
also combined with this it's going to be
combined so
um yeah
uh takes is not really something you
need to worry about because then we have
the similar ideas that we talked about
before of here
and here um and the position is very
good for
for black
but after rook b1 essentially the idea
is to go to h1
and put pressure on h6
g5 for black here but if you play g5
like it just closes out the position
even more and it's going to be even
easier for me to go after your pawns
afterwards so
um in this position i would say maybe
rook b5 looks good um
actually you also have kindly five and a
foot here
king here i would presume
um something like this and it takes
could be an idea
but yeah
i think they didn't take on g6
beforehand because i don't want to trade
as many pawns remember they're going for
the win so i don't really want to trade
pawns if
it's not necessary so
but yeah after rook b1 rookie 8 was
played
and then pawn takes takes and now rook
h1 if you had done at the other move
order the rook will be on
on b1 and not on h1 so that's
that's why but rook h1 now
and it's not really possible to defend
upon
let's say king of king of seven would
you guys take
yeah i'm glad to see you guys are saying
no um
yeah it's it's not good to take right
now
because of pawn takes and this is a
check so there's going to be a big issue
with a rook
right so
after a king of seven king d5
rook to d6 king 2
c4 takes 6
bishop d8 bishop d8 yeah but now
simply f6 was played and this is a very
nice idea
very nice idea because you kind of block
the connection between the rook
and the pawn on h6 and there is no way
that black can successfully
defend it so
yeah if uh king here for example
um i think you're gonna just play rook
g1 and if king goes back rook here
and this is kind of waiting for
for for white so yeah
what about bishop e7 um
like where
oh here bishop e7 that's kind of what
happened in the game
um
i think it has to stop the promotion
can you push f7 the king steps over
um
i don't know what you mean exactly like
if you're
here
[Music]
um
i mean if we go f7 the king can take it
i think and uh h6 is covered
so now the root defensive and if
this you kind of have bishop b7
and i think that's the only move that
stops it so
um yeah so
i mean i just think it's easier probably
to go kinji
sorry rook g1 and
bring the rook to to g7 or g8
eventually and help the promotion of
this phone
also bishop e5 and kd5 are an idea any
time so
um i mean it just looks super good for
white
essentially
um but yeah
so that wasn't played bishop takes f6
was played
and now rook takes bishop b7
how's this end game
i saw a ghost
destroy rooks and go king b5 exactly
trade rooks and go can be fine
uh king b5 bishop e6 was just another
move
it's not any worse with king b5 k6
takes king d7 c4
king c8 bishop takes a5 king
b7 quick question what move would you
guys do here
it's mainly between bishop b4 and c5
so far what do you guys think all of you
c5
a lot of people are commenting c5
i think you guys are beginning to
realize it
yeah so the right move here the right
move here
is um bishop b4
d5 has one extremely big inconvenience
which is bishop takes c5 king takes e5
and kenya
and you guys are not going to be able to
to win this position
as much as you try um simply because
you can't win it if the bishop is not
the same color
as the promotion square so for those of
you who don't know this end game
the bishop is the opposite color as a
promotion square so there's no way that
that the bishop is going to help the
poem promote and
whenever you know pieces get close
trying to help the poem promote
the king on the a8 is going to be still
mated so let me give you an example
let's say like king here came here
push your back here here here like if
you're trying to
to like close up the king like this
it's just gonna be still made um let's
say something like here
here here here kh5 can be seven
you're never going to be able to get the
king out of this horse like kim b5 came
back king
here is a draw like you you won't be
able to win this
essentially so yeah
yeah yeah wrong color bishop theory only
applies to corner squares
um so yeah um
for example if the pawn is in the center
you know how
you know how you know based on the
opposition
you can determine whether it's a draw or
win
but since you have the bishop you can
spend times with the bishop you can
spend you can waste ten posts with the
bishop
and then you force the king to go to
either side and then you enter
with your king through the other one and
you help the pawn promote with your king
does that make sense
um so if the pawn is in the center
you just whenever you need to you spend
a tempo with your bishop
and that's just going to be uh this is
going to be
a winning endgame uh of course draw only
applies to root fonts
and by root points i mean a file or h
file
so yeah um but yeah this is
probably the last trick of the game
uh this is probably the last trick of
the game
but let's go back so not c5
not c5 just bishop b4 bishop to f4
c5 now king a7
c6 can b8 a5
king a7 a6 and you're kind of forcing
the pawns to go
on the opposite color and then you're
going to push the king backwards with
the bishop
king to a8 bishop to c5
bishop to b8 and how do you guys win now
what's the method now
almost everybody got it wrong yeah
that's that's why i asked you guys
it's tricky you can't that's why it's
important to know
the technical endgames and the result of
those technical end games
because you don't want to get a winning
position and then
accidentally mess it up into a draw
because you don't know the technical
engine
so that's why it's important to know
like design games like for example like
the red ski
has a lot of technical languages that's
why it's important to know them so yeah
a7 bishop takes bishop takes king takes
king 2 c5
um but what if a7 i want my bishop
though
bishop b6 you force black to make a
wrong move
what do you mean by a wrong move
remember
if you play like this and the bishop
goes back
it's not like you can play c7 i can take
take
and it's going to be a draw so you're
not really forcing me to make a button
move
but yeah
usually you know this end games go by
stages so you already fulfill this stage
of getting your pawns fart enough
and pushing the king towards a8 and you
know
keeping the king back now you go to the
next stage which is you know actually
promoting the pawns so
how do you do that
you come around exactly so now
for example uh you can go keen c4
and after keen c4 let's say um
bishop c7 and then kindly five bishop d8
king e6 bishop c7 king there
bishop a5 what do you guys do here
how do you win
by the way now that we're talking about
knowing your end games
in the charlotte tournament that i just
finished playing
i was on time pressure with with this
international master
and i was trying to save my position
it looked like it was really bad um
but i was trying to save my position and
um i got into a
knight and rook versus rook and game
and i had to be on the defending side
you know
as you guys probably know that in-game
is a draw but it's very important to
know
your technique otherwise you're in
trouble especially against players that
have more experience than you
uh they can trick you in this endgame so
that's why it's important to always
practice them
and if you can practice them against
computer it's even better because a
computer can't beat you do you really
think that a human will so
um that's one one thing that i can
recommend to you guys to
to learn your technical and games
probably not practical in games that's a
lot harder
but your technical engagements you can
learn um
you can learn that way
yeah exactly if if you're if you're
better in an end game
against someone in a tournament
particularly like they're going to make
you
proof that you know how to checkmate
them so
it doesn't matter if you're on the
defending side or the winning side it's
always important to
to know how to how to win
or uh sorry to know how to play the
endgame right
um and i see that you guys have nice
ideas
just essentially just don't play c7
that's the one thing that's the only
thing i was hoping you guys wouldn't do
c7 and bishop takes skin takes and it's
the same thing it's still made now
actually
um but here you see that the bishop can
beat
on a better diagonal and remember what i
was mentioning of the bishop having two
diagonals to protect
and you can bring the bishop to e7
that's the last move of the oops sorry
that's the last move of the game
and essentially the idea is that for
example bishop v6 let's say bishop here
then c7 and this is just absolutely
crashing for
for white so yeah
um so
yeah can you also do a waiting move
um you could do waiting moves but you
don't really need to
do one here like when you if you have
like a straight
forward win
does your sacrifice work with bishop b4
uh how oh like bishop b4 here
i guess you could play bishop b4 but
they're not going to take they're
probably going to play bishop b6
and it's just a like a move longer i
mean you're still winning
definitely um
but yeah
what's the difference between technical
engineering and practical engineering
technical i would say it's like the
force end game like the end game that
is already traded down to the point
where you can memorize the right
technique
to defend it or win it practical in game
it's more like when you don't fully
understand and you're basing yourself
off of general principles
like let's say if you just traded queens
you're probably on a more practical end
game because there's not a force way to
continue
uh you just have to play based on
principles and your pawn structure
a technical end game is like rook and
pawn against rook
for example where things are already
calculated out and all you need to do is
memorize them internalize it and know
how to defend the position
under any circumstance so that's usually
the difference
like wanting less for an island and
walking into a loss yeah
um he did some he did some uh
slightly poor technique with that b6
move
and not restricting white
before their position got too good so
uh one thing that i can say is don't
play for a drawing in games
play to win or well i guess if you're
losing
then play for a draw if you're inferior
and do play for the draw
but don't just get into an end game you
know like an equal end game and then
play possibly
because you think you can make a draw
easily that way you're just giving
chances to your opponent to
to um how do i say you're just giving
chances to your opponent to
to get a slightly better chance or get
like danish the initiative so
i would say that it's probably better to
to just keep making active moves in the
endgames and
scare your opponents too you know like
maybe they
are the ones that make a mistake and
this mostly goes because when you play
higher rated opponents
oftentimes you kind of want to make a
draw so
you get into like an equal position
equaling game and you think that it's
going to be simple from then on
but then you don't have the best
technique and oftentimes it's because
you're just playing for a draw you're
not playing for a win
and you miss chances that you may have
and you give your opponent chances by
playing too passively so
um that's some advice i can give you
guys
about endgames from what i know and i
hope you guys enjoyed
this other lecture um i think
we're going over to twitch now for
um analyzing your games so you guys will
be submitting games
and i will be analyzing them i think
that's how it works
so um i hope you guys enjoyed this
lecture
um i mentioned it on
the previous lecture like about an hour
ago uh but
if you weren't there uh please follow my
uh please follow my youtube channel
taliatali26
and my twitch tellytali26 i streamed
there today actually analyzed some of my
games
um and you can check those out and um
give it a follow say hi
do whatever you want um
don't tell caleb but i think i like you
slightly better oh thank you
um yeah
so i hope you guys yeah i hope you guys
enjoyed today
uh i think we're going over to twitch so
i hope i can see you guys over there
um see you guys some
other time thank you so much for being
here today
um bye bye